there are 19 sets of parents
who who are never going to get to kiss
their child good night
again
is this the moment to reform gun laws
you know it's it's easy to go to
politics but it's important it's at the
heart of the issue i i get that that's
where the media likes to go it's not
it's where many of the people we've
talked to here like to go the proposals
from democrats in the media
inevitably when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two ar-15s if
you want to stop
violent crime
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this why does
this only happen in your country i
really think that's what many people
around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect of it
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem why is this
just an american problem
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
mass shooting but you can't answer that
you can't answer that can you say you
can't answer that why is this why is it
that people come from all over the world
to america because it's the freest most
prosperous safest country
and it may be the first